this franchise celebrating its 50th
anniversary most franchises do not make
to the milestone what you attribute the
longevity is franchise to I think the
thing that is most enduring about it is
the spirit with which Roddenberry
created this world this family of people
that are sort of all from you know
different cultures backgrounds
ethnicities sex sexual orientations in
this case I think it's about others
finding a family and I think anyone
watching seeing Star Trek could feel
like as much as they do or don't fit
into wherever they are they could be
part of that family and it's a very
optimistic and I don't think
pollyannaish approach to things that I
think indoors you know and and will
continue to do you directed the first
two mm why the decision this time to
pass the conch so to speak over to
Justin estate honestly it was something
that was a necessity because I was
working on force awakens I was shooting
that when we were prepping this I was
you know editing that when they were
shooting this one and I know that it was
the 50th anniversary I knew that
paramount really wanted to make sure
that there was a star trek movie to
honor that so you know I I looked around
at you know various directors and when
Justin's name came up I was excited
because he directed these Fast and
Furious movies with a not just an
incredible skill for action but also a
sort of sense of humor I know move the
movies seem like they're these really
you know intense muscular movie but
doesn't inherit like crazy sense of
humor to those movies he was in on the
joke he got that not only that love Star
Trek grew up watching it with his family
just had such a passion for it the
characters you know the dynamic between
them so talking to him I thought God if
there was a movie that was kind of a
little bit old school embracing the
original series but at the same time
going somewhere that we hadn't gone
before with a kind of level of action
that he was really good at I just
thought it would be an amazing fun night
at the movies and I think he's done it
what about Star Trek again if you could
have any Trek gadget
what would it be any form of technology
could have in a real life what would it
be I mean you know the obvious thing is
the transporter cuz you know you want to
get there fast and who wants to go to
the airport but i think uh you know i'm
in the tricorder which i guess they're
actually working on but something that
allows you to instantly you know
medically you know understand kind of
whatever was going diagnose someone
instantly just with a swipe of a you
know device that would probably save
lives so while the transporter is sort
of the fun answer the sort of the i
think the smarter answer is the
tricorder as a franchise guy who's been
responsible for reboots of a number of
series what do you think of of the talk
of Aegis elbow playing the next Bond
would you like to see that what are your
thoughts on it he's I mean he's if he
beat incredible he's unbelievable yeah
um I can't member who it was who
criticized him and said that he was to
you know street someone flex I said that
it was like I you want him to be bond if
not just to disprove that yeah but also
he's so damn good um the only problem is
he's not a taller handsome enough the
guys later literally you look at the guy
you go yeah he could do anything oh yeah
Rihanna what what you know why did you
want her you know sledgehammer is that
important how important are soundtracks
why did you want her to be a part of
this movie what happen was you know we
were work on this movie first trailer
came out she saw the trailer big fan of
Trek she apparently had had this song
that SIA had written that I guess she'd
been playing with but she suddenly was
like oh my god she literally recorded
the song and sent it over wow I was like
we love you know this movie we love the
franchise here's the song you guys want
it and it just felt like there was a
epic sort of emotional quality you know
classic SIA anthem you know big deeply
felt sort of thing Justin you know loved
it and so just if we thought it was a
fun way to you know bring a kind of
energy to
the movie and a level of you know
attention partly because you know Trek
was seen for a long time as like oh my
uncle's thing my dad's thing the pallino
the idea that Rihanna you know who
obviously is genius and on fire the fact
that she would you know be excited about
it made us like well that's kind of what
the movie feels like it's a it's a very
you know youthful energy to move without
youthful energy and just felt like it
sort of felt appropriate in that way
Justin loved it and we went with